[Music]
the climate threat is not new we've
known for a few decades that this was
going to be the big issue in the 21st
century
this is clearly the biggest threat to
the planet we have an emergency
[Music]
we have this whole new injection of
people in the last ten years young
hungry ambitious eager engineers who
want to do great things it started out as
an academic pursuit but once we started
working on this it seemed like we might
actually be on to something you have a
set of these small startups run by you
know these really young idealistic
people who have kind of come up with
these really innovative designs call it
nuclear 2.0 we wanted to develop a new
type of nuclear reactor that can consume
existing stockpiles of nuclear waste we
need to be building reactors all over
the world as soon as we can if we care
about climate if we care about dealing
with emissions we need to build nuclear
so they don't build coal or burn other
fossil fuels I want to build an advanced
reactor in the next decade so that we
can build them all across the planet to
put this simply a nuclear reactor is not
an app this is not the kind of idea that
can be fueled on pizza and lines of code
the risk is proportional to the reward
and this is about as big as it gets
[Music]
I'm Ross Koningstein.
I worked on
Google's effort to make renewable energy
cheaper than coal.
we published a bunch
of material from this, I realized that
slowing or reversing climate change
could not be addressed without new
energy technologies coming to bear,
particularly cost-effective ones.
And In
2014 I founded the nuclear energy R&D
group here at Google.
And we wanted to
see how we might accelerate R&D in
advanced technology.
something that could
bring about more scalable zero-carbon
always available cheaper energy for
humanity.
For those of you who are not
students of nuclear science, nuclear
processes are fundamental to matter and
energy in our universe.
We are made of
matter that was formed through slow
fusion in stars and our heavier elements
were formed through supernova experiment
experiments huh
not so much
supernovae and nuclear decay.
Nature is naturally radioactive so
the nearest radioactive sources
right near me in fact comes from the
potassium-40 that is decaying in my
panelists and myself.
So on that note I'm
looking forward to some scintillating
discussions with this group of
innovators and experts.
So first off
let's introduce David David Schumacher an
award winning actually Emmy award-winning
director and producer of the new fire
welcome you're a graduate of the Berklee
School of Music and then took a
left-hand turn to go into the world of
film under esteemed filmmakers
such as Barbara Kopple and Ken Burns.
I think most of us are aware of one or
two works that Ken Burns has worked on
that's great.
You became really inspired
and driven to work on the new fire as we
have talked about several times this is
great and you tie it to the
environmental need the technological
abilities and the opportunities that are
out there that's great.
Our next panelist Caroline Cochran.
She is
the co-founder and COO at Oklo Inc
a company named after a naturally-occurring
reactor in Gabon, if I remember correctly
so Caroline
earned her BA in economics and her BS in
mechanical engineering from the
University of Oklahoma and her MS and
nuclear engineering from MIT.
She has a
background working on solar vehicles
natural gas oil refining and of course
nuclear engineering and her company Oklo
is working on clean energy plants for
microgrids where advanced fission
reactors can pair and work along with
renewables so it's pretty exciting.
Tyler Ellis is founder and principal of
Ellis, black Ellis partners pardon me he
received a PhD, SM and SB degrees from MIT
in nuclear science and engineering and
also an MBA from Harvard that's probably our
most decorated panelist.
Previously Tyler was
on the founding team at Terra Power
which is a Bill Gates’ backed nuclear
energy company and now at Black Hills
Partners.
He is an entrepreneur investor
scientific adviser who works with both
the private and public sector to bring
high impact energy technologies to
market and Mengyao, Mengyao Yuan is a
postdoctoral research scientist at the
Carnegie Institution for science at Stanford.
She recently got her PhD at
Stanford for studying carbon capture and
other low carbon technologies and her
current research focuses on modeling
analysis of near zero emission energy
systems.
So thank you all so much for
being with us here today and so let's
talk about advanced nuclear energy
technology and the solutions and
opportunities that it may present for
the future.
So perhaps let's start with
some maybe you could provide a little
motivation for each of you to let the
audience know what you're about.
yes
David yeah well I'm not I went to music
school in Boston and then on 150 Mass Ave.
and I
found myself on the other side of the
Charles River at Mass Ave.
at MIT why would I go and do this I was
just worried about climate like
everybody else
and when I sort of realized that the
science about how do you decarbonize was
not really being followed by the
policymakers and the just general public
opinion people had no concept of how do
we actually decarbonize and what role
nuclear would have to play I felt like
well this is really worrisome because
I'm we have to solve this problem and
the rate we're going we're just it's not
going to happen and so I felt like
that's kind of a bold statement and kind
of a very contrarian statement perhaps
and maybe not the most popular type of thing
to do but I felt like once I sort of met
some people that were working in this
field and I found you know saw these
amazing sort of heroic folks who were
really just the dedicated to providing
clean energy for the world even if it's
misunderstood at this time I thought the
people have to see this because I was so
amazed by what I learned that to be able
to present that journey of discovery
that I went through to other people and
they could see the whole get the whole
thing at the 85 minutes as opposed to
you know spending three years doing all
of this that's that's what I felt was
really exciting about it great Thank You
Caroline I think in some ways my journey
parallels David's not entirely I was
engineering in undergraduate but I
didn't know anything about nuclear at
all and met some nuclear engineers
actually Tyler and an undergraduate
engineering internship in DC I was
mostly interested in policy I thought I
was gonna go to grad school and robotics
with mechanical engineering and really
just became convinced every I was very
skeptical about nuclear we learn more
and more about it and I my kind of
underlying passion is the environment and
health and just realized that this is
one silver bullet that you don't really
you really don't see something quite
this impactful so I became passionate
about it decided to go work for a year
reapply to grad school and that's how I
ended up at MIT
My co-founder Jacob DeWitte who's here actually
today was passionate about
commercializing something in advance
nuclear and so I became part of that
group but what we really realize this
people needed this kind of power what
we're looking at now they needed it
yesterday basically these microgrids are just
starving for clean reliable
power so that's how we really got
focused in on this really really small
concept great Thank You Tyler yeah mine
actually starts back to freshman year we
had to pick your major and then I said
okay I got into a good school I think I
should work on something that's high
impact to society and I said okay we
have genetically modified crops for food
we have desalination technologies for
water we have cheap building materials
for shelter but energy is really the
underpinning factor that we don't know
how we're gonna get all that it is we
need to get I said okay I'll work on
that and then I looked at all the energy
funds that you could scale up without
emitting massive amounts of co2 in the
interim and it's okay nuclear technology
is the best option there I said I'm
gonna work on that I spent about seven and
a
half years at MIT and then subsequently
worked with several other startups
Afterwards Great.
And Mengyao.
Yeah, so what got me started in the energy
and environment space is Captain Planet and
the Planeteers, which I really enjoyed watching
as a kid.
But what keeps me going is just a sense of
accomplishment I get from doing something
I find meaningful.
so I have a question for David
so of course congratulations with the
the release of the film which was like
this weekend right yeah Friday yeah
Thursday and I think you've told
us a bit about your motivation behind
the story.
Can you tell us about the
reactions at the film festivals and what
you think the path for the film will
be well I think that the you know the
path with the film is just gonna be
number one box office smash worldwide
no I mean it the point of the
Film this isn't a commercial film I mean
when you go about making a film like a
documentary you have to ask yourself why
am I doing this
and there's generally three buckets that
could fall and it could be to make that
money you know I want to make as much
money as I possibly can
or it could be I want to be famous I
want as many people to see this film and
awards and reviews and everything and
it's a really big deal or I want to
change the world and I'd love to do the
first two don't get me wrong but my main
priority with this film was changing the
world and I think that the thing that it
could it was able to do and the biggest
concern that I had was that people who
are concerned about the environment and
concerned about climate and sincere
about that just don't understand nuclear
and don't understand the role that
nuclear can play to really solve this
plant and solve this problem this energy
problem this climate problem this social
justice around energy problem
sustainable development problem nuclear
is something really interesting that can
really help with all of those issues and
I felt that if I could somehow bring a
story that can appeal to those
sensibilities of those type of people
and get you know them to accept
especially advanced nuclear and the role of
innovation we're already doing a lot
of renewables we're already doing
storage we're already working on
efficiency systems thinking all of that
stuff what else can we do because this
is a big problem the biggest problem
we've ever had as a species
what about technology what's next in a
pipeline and if you think about it in
that respect the development pipeline
the low-hanging fruit in energy is
nuclear so I think it's really
interesting and I hope that
environmentalists will see that this is
that we're environmentalist too and
that's I mean Caroline could even talk
about she was at the screening at the
world's largest environmental film
festival environmental film festival in
the nation's capital and we're accepted
as environmentalists I mean it's amazing
and we've been at four environmental film
festivals and that's really amazing so
one of the things that many people might
not know is that some of these film
screenings have Q and A's what were the
reactions like from the people who saw
the film I would say that we've had some
really great reactions I had one couple that
came
after up to me after our screening at
the Philadelphia Film Festival
environmental film festival and they
said you know we were we live downwind
from the Three Mile Island these were
older folks than me they were young
adults living around Three Mile Island
when that happened and they were very
scared and it became very anti-nuclear
in the wake of that and started a branch
of the Sierra Club and they were very
anti and they said you know we they came
up to me they said you know we have a
friend who's been pro-nuclear and she's
been trying to convince us and it hasn't
worked but you know seeing this film and
seeing these the next generation
reactors and the people behind it made
us you know really interested and inspired
and I think now we actually changed our
minds and that was a really big deal I
mean I think it's a big deal for people
that changed their minds but I think
also at these environmental film
festivals there's a lot of disaster porn
you know there's so much bad news in the
environmental space that to bring a
positive solutions based story was kind
of a really nice palate cleanse and
beyond that it was just the way in
contrast everything else so I mean I
could have asked for a better quality of response
than what we've
gotten from the environmental film
festivals in particular but film
festivals in general I would say that's
great.
Well let's let's switch gears a
little into a technology in the systems
view so I think as we all know you know
in the early 1900's a telephone was this
40-pound box that was attached to the
wall of your house and you had to hand crank
it and here we are today and we
carry you know something that you can
call anybody in the world from and it
fits in your pocket and it happens to
have a computer and all sorts of other
good stuff in it.
Nuclear
technology sadly has not seen the same
rate of advance however there are a
number of advances that have occurred
and Mengyao I wonder if you might talk a
little bit about what you think of from
traditional nuclear energy which is
basically 1950s technology and how that
fits into the energy system and compare
that perhaps with the possibilities of
advanced technology nuclear.
So yeah so
traditionally nuclear power is a
large-scale zero emission technology
and has played an important role in the
u.s. energy system nuclear currently
represents 20 percent
of the electricity generation in the US
and more than half of the country’s
carbon-free electricity the energy
system is changing rapidly however and
nuclear faces competition from cheap
natural gas especially in the US as well
as increasing penetration of wind and
solar PV and because of the variable
generation from wind and solar
we need technologies that can fill the
gap between variable demand and variable
generation and currently natural gas is
filling this role but to minimize the
impact on the climate we would need
substitutes that are carbon free and
these technologies would also need to be
cost competitive with natural gas
because eventually everything would need
to compete on dollar per kilowatt hour
basis future energy technologies will
also need to be reliable and flexible to
accommodate the variability in the grid
and they would also need to be climate
resilient to adapt to the more
challenging operating conditions caused
by climate change and advanced nuclear
technologies could be an important
player in a future energy system if they
can tick these boxes and I look forward
to learning from the other panelists
about this topic thank you thank you
well let's let's hop to that panelists
so Caroline you are in an advanced
nuclear energy startup could you tell us
what that's like yeah well you know in
the movie it says it's not like an app
that's true um in some ways but in some
ways it actually is believe it or not
and that's part of why we're based here
in Silicon Valley is because we feel
like the focus that's on developing
and turning out something quickly is
really important we're part I think it's
we also friends who are doing other kind
of really cutting-edge things like
quantum computing and things like that
but I almost think this is it's harder
than that in a way because we're not
just trying to break new ground but
we're trying to break new ground and
such an old industry and kind of like
what was mentioned by the other
panelists we've got an industry where
it's no joke they still use analog
devices frequently okay so we're talking
dials and levers and stuff um and so
we're trying to do this and a totally
new kind of reactor using tested
technologies from the labs from decades
ago but basically totally new in a
commercial sense for the micro grids but
trying to do within an industry that is
incredibly backwards and not necessarily
always friendly to that kind of kind of
new innovation so it is I think we're in
a really interesting spot in that way
we're trying to use computers you know
now with computing power you can
actually model an entire reactor used to
be you really couldn't do that and so
you know using Python and using modern
scripting and computing capabilities to
really turn this around much quicker and
much cheaper so um yeah it's a really
unique space okay so you have the
perspective of innovator Tyler I'd like
to turn to you and get the perspective
of somebody who helps make things happen
in funding advice etc so in the nuclear
space there's about 30 startups
operating today in advanced nuclear what
do you see as some of the things that
that need to happen there to really make
that successful yeah so I mean each
individual company and Technology
approach kind of has their own specific
things that would be most beneficial so
you know for one company maybe their
central technical risk is a new
materials development program for
another company maybe it's a you know
complex simulation and finding kind of
the optimum topology of reactor layout
so kind of each individual concept and
company kind of has their own you know
set of technical milestones that's that
would be most helpful in the like in the
investment space I think there's a
variety of interesting things that are
happening there with the rise of a lot
of new funds that have longer timelines
and providing access to physical
facilities in order to perform a lot of
earlier stage prototype development and
proof-of-concept without having to spend
all the money to build up one of those
types of facilities and then just
generally connecting
those types of organizations with large
strategic companies that can help them
scale up or help them learn how to better
really ramp that up into a
commercially viable type of design and
then on the regulatory front I think
there's a number of kind of interesting
developments there as well as far as the
NRC is entirely rate based they're about
a 90 percent of their fees are recovered
from you know the rate payers but
they're starting to change some of those
requirements such that you know smaller
companies can go and talk to them and
have interactions you know for for
establishing kind of a large-scale
design that's between like forty to a
hundred million dollars which is pretty
expensive for a lot of early-stage
startups but you're starting to see
movement in that space in order to try
and alleviate that burden so kind of new
or more exciting technologies have a
shot at actually getting to market
without having to raise hundreds of
millions to billions of dollars to get
over that hump because that high amount
of capital you know is a pretty
significant barrier to entry for a lot
of the older space startups so you have
to be really keenly focused on what is
that central technical risk let's do
what we can to take maximum risk out early
and then use that to justify
the subsequent round of financing yes that
definitely is one of the challenges in
nuclear space because energy is about
10% of the world economy
so the potential revenue stream is huge
but you know scaling your company and
technologies to deliver that you need money
to make that happen.
Great well
I'd like to turn now to the panel part
of our discussion and I'd like to talk
I'd like us to talk for a little bit about
the circular economy so the circular
economy is somewhere where you reduce
your environmental footprint by
designing out waste remanufacturing your
products or regenerating your systems so
that your waste stream becomes
incredibly small and hopefully your
supply stream also becomes quite strong
small of course to do this you tend to
need to add energy and you know
processing to make these things work so
for example Google has realized quite a
few savings as well as reductions in
waste in our own implementation of
circular economy in the management of
our data center hardware so nobody likes
to throw out a lot
of you know used electronic equipment so
if you can close that cycle and minimize
your waste stream then you have a much
smaller environmental impact energy
technology can play a real role in
this and so I'm wondering if we could
talk a little bit about the circular
principles of reduce reuse recycle etc
and how we could embed that much at a
larger scale into a society's
infrastructure how do you see the next
generation of nuclear reactors fitting
into that picture so I mean just to kind
of reiterate what you said you know the
amount of waste itself is actually
incredibly small you know when you look
at you know it's a football field 9 foot
high which is the waste stream for the
entire United States 20% of our
electricity generation for about 60
years
you know if an individual got 100
percent of their electricity from
nuclear energy and lived to be a hundred
their waste would fit inside of a Coke can
it's very well contained very small
so it's a fairly small amount to deal
with a lot of the existing nuclear
reactors burn about 0.7% of kind of all
uranium that exists there's two isotopes
u-235 u-238
many of the advanced reactor designs can
go upwards of you know close to 50%
utilization which is a significant
expansion as far as the uranium
utilization and then also once you
actually split that uranium in there
there are a variety you get basically
the entire periodic table in your spent fuel
elements so there are a variety of
uses from any of those isotopes for
medical applications you know
molybdenum-99 at Kazon to technetium-99
which we use for 20 million imaging
procedures in the medical field today so
I think there's a lot of opportunities
with many of those advanced technologies
to increase the utilization and or reuse
their fuel for you know making new fuels (mumble).
Mengyao, I think you had a comment, no
So, I'd like to add to that if there's extra
time I like once I learned about
nuclear I found it's really the it's
almost like the ultimate circular
economy situation because you can try to
recycle a lot of things but very few
things can you recycle and produce clean
electricity at the same time
so that's really what's so amazing about
it and part of why we're passionate
about our technology - it's one of the
ones that Tyler was mentioning where you
can really make use of the entire well a
large portion of the remainder of the
nuclear fuel that's been used that's why
sometimes people call it used nuclear fuel
instead of waste because one
analogy is like if you buy the liter pop
and took a sip and threw it away we can
use a good portion of the remainder of
that so that's really important to us is
making closing than what we call closing the
nuclear fuel cycle but also like you
thinking about all so many different
products for use today maybe we can try
to recycle them but they use an
incredible amount of energy to recycle
so the carbon footprint of recycling and
sometimes greater than just making it
new although you're still talking about
resource impacts on the globe right and
in the environment and so we have to
focus on what has the lowest carbon
lifecycle footprint and that's really
nuclear by a long shot um when you when
you account for whether or not you have
to have backup power or storage for an
energy source and then if you take that
which is already incredibly low carbon
footprint and then recycle it then you
really have an incredible situation for
the environment so that's why we're real
excited about it and now you mentioned
the electric part but there's also the
primary energy part where you know the
large-scale use of natural gas or other
fuels that go into manufacturing
I just wanted throw something out here
is that we're talking about the waste so
when people hear about nuclear waste
does anybody worry about that well
that's reasonable because when you
pulled spent fuel out of a reactor
that's pretty nasty stuff right then and
there and you know you definitely only
be anywhere near it or you won't live
very long but the thing I think is
really interesting it's the reason that
I'm making this film at all is because
of fossil fuel waste that here in the
United States we're putting 100 million tons
of it into the atmosphere this week and
every week that's how much we do just in
the United States we use about 10% of
the world's energy I think it is and yet
we're worried about a football field of
spent fuel how many people know the
difference between high level waste and
other waste so when you hear about the 5
million gallons of high level waste does
anybody know what that is so that's the
scary stuff the high level waste is from
military when they were doing the
Manhattan Project and they're just in
such a rush to let's get the bomb as
fast as we can we weren't really worried
that much about the waste and so forth
so there are some millions of gallons of
waste that has not been fully remediated
yet and you know so that's kind of the
cost of getting the the bomb finished in
time and finishing the Second World War
however on the nuclear energy side every
bit of nuclear spent fuel nuclear waste
that is produced by the nuclear energy
industry is collected by the nuclear
energy industry is controlled by the
nuclear industry there's never been a
fatality from that for many you know
civilians certainly and it's a it's a
big lie out there about nuclear waste is
something dangerous I mean imagine if
the fossil industry collected and
controlled its waste imagine if that
happened we wouldn't need to have this
climate problem, would we but yet here we
are
worrying about nuclear waste no one's
ever died from it so who benefits from
that that's the question I want to know
your fear of nuclear waste of radiation
who benefits from that because you're
not supporting nuclear so then if people
don't support it it's not gonna get
built and what fills the void think
about that on that thought-provoking
note let's shift a discussion to what's
next so just sort of anybody please
comment what do you think is needed to
scale the advanced nuclear reactor
industry well please happy to go I
think there's a variety of things for a
lot of the new startups kind of as I
mentioned before having
sort of a new mechanisms in the
regulatory side is gonna be very
beneficial so as I mentioned it's very
capital-intensive to have any sort of a
regulatory review so that would have a
very massive impact I think another
thing that you could do would be right
now each individual state has a
renewable portfolio standard and they
actually define winners as only wind or solar,
so they kind of artificially
selecting winners I think the original
intent of the legislation is really to
encourage non co2 emitting generation so
if individual state by state basis we
were to go around and say okay let's
change the definition from only wind and
solar to all non emitting generation
sources I think that would go a long way
towards helping uh helping that out and
then I had one other but oh I'm sorry
the public-private partnership site I
think there's a variety of interesting
mechanisms that could be used to a lot
of Department of Energy experts and
other experts in the government can have
public/private interactions with the
private industry so whether that's
leveraging a lot of their large testing
facilities at National Labs so you
startups don't have to rebuild all of
that or tap into some of that expertise
I think they can go a long way and then
one of the other things that was really
beneficial in the NASA COTS program
which basically provided about four
hundred million dollars to SpaceX and
allowed SpaceX to be the success that it
is today from from other companies that
didn't win that award like SpaceX they
were actually able to interact with NASA
experts and then have NASA sign off on
the technology approach and then have
independent experts say yeah that's
reasonable if you build that that will
work then they're able to take that to
the private investors and say oh well
you have NASA experts signed off on that
you know we're gonna fund you to get to
your next milestone that actually
encouraged a lot more innovation to
happen which was phenomenal beyond just
the individual winner of the
public-private partnership.
I think that what's
interesting about what Tyler is talking
about though is it's different between
nuclear and and you know space travel
and when SpaceX is all about is that who
doesn't want to see that type of you
know
they're talking about going to Mars you
know like that's exciting who isn't
excited about that but in a nuclear
business we're gonna build a new reactor
like hey people just don't get as
excited you don't capture the
imagination of the public but it really
should because this is how you get off
fossil fuels and after all it's all
about keeping it in the ground that's
what we have to do is keep fossil fuels
in the ground so if you ever wondering
about a problem with nuclear like the
safety safety no one's ever died from a
nuclear plant including Three Mile
Island in the United States ever yeah
what happened in San Bruno a few years
ago with natural gas so we didn't have a
moratorium on natural gas after a bunch
of people died when there's a big
natural gas explosion in their
neighborhood but yet you know at
Fukushima happens which nobody who died
from radiation at Fukushima either and
Germany shuts down everybody shuts down
and it's just amazing because who
benefits from this and who fills the
void fossil fossil is still the fastest
growing form of energy in the world
right now out of all of the new energy
that the capacity that's put out in the
world renewables is only about a third
less than that the vast majority of a
new energy is filled with fossil and so
you're not even replacing existing the
only thing that is ever you know worked at
the scale and speed necessary in
the world is nuclear, but some people
aren't gonna be happy about that
because if you think about the energy
industry it's 10% of the world
technology and the fossil industry is a
multi trillion dollar industry it's
crazy it's huge amounts of money nuclear
is a few billion dollars a year in the
fuel space because it's basically free
fuel doesn't cost thing right like one
gram of uranium has about saying that
ash is two tons of coal and in those two
tons of coal there's four parts per
million of uranium so when they're
Burning two tons of coal they're
actually spewing more uranium out there
into the earth for all of us to breathe
and whatever then you would need to burn
in a reactor to create the same amount
energy in the first place and then you'd
have waste from one gram
of uranium which is like a size of a pea
so this is how insane it all is and why
because public opinion people afraid of
radiation people afraid of nuclear
safety people afraid of all that but if
you look at the facts what's the most
dangerous form of energy they ain't
nuclear, it's coal.
Nuclear's at the
bottom it's the safest form of energy
along with renewables and you know hydro
is actually much more dangerous because
people have you know had there's been
bad accidents but there's it's not
dangerous and radiation it turns out
that we're way over afraid of radiation
there's no exactly the amount of
radiation required in a year so you
evacuate from a place according to you
know health physics society and the EPA and
other guidelines it's 100 millisieverts
annual dose well there's no biological
evidence of anybody ever getting cancer
having a bad health outcome from
receiving less than 100 millisieverts
not over a year but over the course of a
few seconds to a few minutes nobody's
ever died from a cat-scan nobody's ever
died from an MRI nobody's ever died from
a PET scan nobody's ever died for a
chest x-ray that's never happened
there's no evidence of it yet here we
are being told these risks that are not
real risks it's all like it's something
everything is upside down and nuclear
everything I thought I knew was wrong
and it's just it's bonkers but it's so liberating
it I just hope some of
you folks look into this it's really
interesting so it's really interesting
to see that if you're particularly
data-driven and you can set aside your
feelings on the matter then you can
arrive at this kind of conclusion right
but you know most people who actually
don't have a lot of information they
rely on things they see and hear what do
you think about the importance of having
demonstrations of new technology in the
nuclear space that the public could
somehow see and use as a basis for
re-evaluating perhaps what they think
yeah yeah like that's actually a perfect
segue cuz I was just going to echo what
Dave is saying and Tyler is saying but
also you know how we scale this up or
how do we really change things I think we
have to build
it I don't think we necessarily need
huge government programs do that I think
huge government programs usually lead to
the kinds of outcomes so you don't want
to see in this industry which is more
backwards thinking and more kind of anti
innovation thinking which is what we're
battling basically every day right and then
what's really behind all this there's
not a big motive there because there
isn't the education the stuff that
Dave's talking about people aren't
passionate like you see people have
learned some things and then they get
really passionate it's really amazing
but by and large like you're saying
people aren't and so there isn't the
motivation for the politicians to push
things or to give credits or I think it
all comes down to what people really
want and I think when you build
something especially our reactors kind
of what we call community size so it's
small enough that there's really nothing
that can happen to it and you can have a
small piece of land where people could
come and actually come pretty close to
the reactor because it is that safe and
we can demonstrate that and then they
can see it and they can feel in a touch
it and I think it's not as foreboding as huge
plants that have you know large
amounts of water intake like we don't
require any water and you can't come
anywhere close and there's huge guards
and you know guns and fences and all
those other things so yeah I think
that's a huge part of it it's just
building it and letting people see it
firsthand and letting them make their
own decisions and giving them education
to know what's real what's not real yeah
we have the interaction is a huge part I
mean if you get greater social licence
when you actually bring people in and
show them as opposed to oh this is super
secret you can't you can't see what
we're doing we're gonna do a put a black
box around everything and then users
have to trust us so having that
interaction I think is very key for kind
of the next generation to be successful
and deploying new technologies what
we're seeing to as communities are
already opting in instead of sort of
saying okay we have this huge plan we
have to site in this one you know kind
of low cost area and so poor people end
up having to move or whatever it has a
socioeconomic effect but when you
have this small thing that communities
can decide to opt in on because it's
small enough and cost-effective enough
for them to do that we are seeing
communities that are saying hey I want that
for mine, and
that might be Native American
communities or our small communities up
in Alaska and so we're basically already
having what's almost like a early
purchase list because there's
communities are like hey I want that in
my community I want my community to be entirely
carbon free and so we can pair
that with renewables and have you know
electricity at night or when the wind
doesn't blow or when it's really dark
and extremely cold in Alaska and so I
think there's incredible power if you
can have an opt-in situation great so
another advantage I would think of to
build more reactors is to drive down
the cost of nuclear because currently
the high capital costs especially of
nuclear is a barrier that prevents I
think further development of nuclear so by
building more reactors we could learn from
the
experience and potentially lower the
cost of this technology great so we have
a number of people here in the audience
today and a number of people who are
likely watching us through the internet
do you have any words of wisdom or
advice to people who are interested in
in learning more about this wanting to
make a positive impact on the world or
simply get involved somehow in the
nuclear conversation
Well, the first place to start is check out
the movie’s website, newfiremovie.com
Commercial plug.
The thing that we’ve done on the film on
this website that we just relaunched or expanded
out is that it explains a bit about the
technology and it has links to all sorts
of different sources of information so
if you want a jumping-off point to get
into you know learning about this if you
go to the website that's a pretty easy
place to start that's what I was going
to say yeah we participated in this film
because I feel like there isn't a great
there's not like a single great source
to point people to people are like hey I
want to learn about advanced fission
like what is it how does it differ from
older plants what is nuclear at all um
I'm not I don't have like a lot of
resources I'm like oh this is a really
great way and user friend
not really technologically dense to
learn about this and that's part of why
we participate in this film it's
hopefully like it gets the word out
about what's going on and a little bit
about the tech and then the website has
more resources so yeah additional plug
so I completely agree with all of that I
mean I think the the big thing that I
would say would be to start today don't
start tomorrow or next week we've been
enough delay so we've people if you want
to get involved involved now I think
reaching out to a variety of startup
companies in the nuclear space are a great
way to get involved you know you can
either help them out and you know some
way shape or form and that can kind of
put you on the cutting edge of a lot of
that technology I think that's a really
exciting way to learn about the
technology as it's being you know
developed and kind of reengineered I
mean there are a few other industrial
websites where you can do a little bit
of additional background reading so
nuclear energy institute is a pretty
good source of information the world
nuclear Association is another good
source of information if you want to do
background reading that can kind of give
you a rough lay of the land and
understanding of the technology
Just keep calm and carry on
ok great
well I think we are coming up on our Q&A
period.
Camila, do we have some questions
can everyone hear me so one of the questions
we had
come in was it seems apparent that we
can no longer reduce carbon we have to
remove it from the atmosphere should we
use the need for energy to sequester
carbon to justify nuclear energy
Yes!
- Other thoughts?
cool things I think about
having such an energy dense and non
carbon emitting source of electricity is
you can do really wild things so we've
looked into pulling carbon out of the
atmosphere and basically making a carbon
neutral form of fuel for vehicles or
planes you can do that when you have
such an energy dense form of electricity
you can you can do desalination and it
really
effective ways but yeah pulling carbon
out of the atmosphere is one of the
things that nuclear can be really well-suited
to
okay I would just say that I think it's
probably better to use the nuclear
energy to sort of produce energy and
offset fossil and get rid of fossil and
then once we're at, you know, zero fossil
or as close to that as we can get then
start using it to suck the energy there
the co2 out but that's a small point
yeah a big part of the challenge though
is there has to be some there has to be
some mechanism that values removing co2
from the atmosphere because right now
there's no economic way with which that
is valued so I think one of the big
things for that is actually just being
able to have some sort of a market
mechanism that addresses and values that
sort of you know that sort of technology
approach and then as soon as something
like that happens and you're gonna see a
lot more a lot more movement but
nuclear's
I think probably the best way of being
able to actually power facility like
that before you had mentioned using last
gen waste as next gen fuel does that
limit at all where these next
gen reactors can be built do they have
to be built next to waste sites from former
sites or can they be dispatched in
other locations yeah it's pretty small
the fuel part is only five percent of
the cost of nuclear electricity so even
if you were to spend a little bit more
money or have it be a slightly more
complex process it really doesn't impact
the net price of electricity much at all
and then you know the the kind of the
choice between using fresh uranium fuel
versus using a used fuel it's more of a
kind of an economic question because you
know remanufacturing old fuel or
reusing old fuel will cost a bit more
money but then performance aside, it is kind
of a society-level question of you know
where do we make our investment in and
how much do we value you know utilizing
that used nuclear stockpile fuel and then
manufacturing new you know new fuel
elements from that versus paying for a
repository or something like that so it
really kind of comes down to you know
what that particular society is
optimizing for you know we're trying to
have you know the smallest repository
possible or you know for okay using dry
cask storage on reactor sites, or just what
the desired mix is that'll
be different for each country and I
think a great question is can you define
advanced nuclear
I'll start, I guess, there are a lot of different
definitions so that makes it kind of tough.
You know Congress defined it, they have politically
motivated definitions that
are like any reactor after a certain
year I think usually when people say
advanced they mean non light water
reactors so in other words all the
existing commercial reactors the United
States today use you know huge amounts
of water and they use water for cooling
in moderation so ours doesn't a lot of
these advanced technologies don't there
are some other people who would define
advanced is more or less having what we
call passive safety characteristics so
in other words inherent safety so even
if react an operator wasn't there the
reactor literally couldn't meltdown so
there are some light water reactors that
have some of those safety characteristics
what we call passive safety
characteristics so sometimes they get
lumped into the advanced reactor bundle
so it kind of just depends on what you
want to call it I think usually people
use it as a way to define newer
technology so in the last couple decades
these passive safety to ensure that
there is no meltdown capability so I
think that the important thing to think
about when you're thinking about what is
an advanced reactor is it's and why
would you want an advanced reactor is
precisely building on what Caroline said
right now we have to use water as a
coolant and you have to get up to about 300
degrees Celsius or something like
that and water boils naturally at a
hundred degrees Celsius so I think that
means you have to be at 150 atmospheres
pressure so you got to keep that water
at that level and imagine the amount of
you know the the size of what you're
dealing with in the magnitude and the
strength of everything and it has to be
failsafe and has to run 100% at a time
for 40 years that's a big ask on
materials and on you know this big plant
where if you say well why don't we just
use material like a coolant that can't
evaporate you know and we can get it up
to like a thousand degrees
there's no way it's ever going to
evaporate and it could just run it at atmospheric
pressure well as soon as you
do that it just gets way smaller and way
less complicated and way fewer parts and
way simpler so why didn't we ever do
that before because we didn't have the
materials at the time when they you know
in in the 1950s when they needed to get
a reactor going it was like what can we
get going it's gonna work right now and
that we can put in a submarine and it's
gonna work right now and it was, like, a light
water reactor that made perfect sense but
in the past sixty years with all the
developments and materials and
everything else that's happened the fact
that we're still using water as the coolant
in nuclear reactors is just I
mean it's great but it's like it's like
going to Cuba and going oh look at all
these great old cars it's so nice you
know, '57 Edsel, that's so great and it's
like but don't you think the people of
Cuba want to be driving Tesla's like
everybody else
I mean it's charming but we need we need
new technology and we need the pop
social license and we need people
demanding it if you want to get off
fossil fuel if you want to get at the
fossil industry and make them real mad
and hit him where it hurts advocate for nuclear,
this kind of nuclear
and so to that point the current state
of the nuclear industry what what is
happening with these old reactors from
the 1950s are they being shut down with
any replacements are they being upgraded
how is that changing well I think
there's a couple of things that dynamic
wise that are changing so I mentioned
one the renewable portfolio standards
and individual states which is actually
mandating a certain percentage of
electricity which has to be purchased
from either wind or solar and the way
that a lot of those markets work is that
they quote out the total number of
megawatts they need for the day and each
individual state will say okay well this
certain percentage has to be for wind
and solar and that moves all the other
resources out of the stack and because
of the advent of cheap natural gas it's
actually pushing what used to be one of
the cheapest sources of electricity
generation which is nuclear fission
power plants out of the stack and making
it challenging for them to be able to
actually sell all their electricity so
that's why you're actually seeing a lot
of
challenges with regards to should we
keep this plant open or not I mean these
are very long-lived assets you know
they're originally licensed for 40 years
but we're doing license extensions for
60 and likely 80 years they're replacing
a lion's share of the components in
there so you know these already
constructed facilities can operate for a
very long period of time but you know
really it's a it's kind of a market type
of a dynamic and you know the advent of
the renewable portfolio standards have
really changed that dynamic of being
able to sell that electricity so I think
that's the challenge it's not a it's not
a waste issue it's not a it was
partially kind of related to a cost
issue but it's because the market was
actually changed the rules of the games
were changed and that's what actually is
really hurting a lot of existing
generation now that's it one interesting
thing though that's happened the last
couple decades is massive upgrades to these
plants so we've added maybe 8 gigawatts of
clean
electricity to the grid just because
these plants use advanced technologies
to grow larger and produce more clean
electricity it's really valuable
obviously for the grid because it's
that's 9 gigawatts we don't have to
produce using something else that's a
really good story for the environment
even if we don't think that those are
necessarily the kinds of plants we
should be building now I've been really
happy to see some of that so these
plants are operating at 95 plus percent
capacity factor so almost 24/7 and if
you can get squeezed out you know you
know double-digit percentages greater
power out of the same plant and that's
what they've been doing just because the
need for power has been great and they
had I mean as you mentioned before the
the better computational tools so the way
these reactors were designed in kind of
the 1950's and 40s they had very large
margins in there and then after they've
kind of sharpen the pencil with a lot of
their advanced computational tools they
realize oh wow we can actually get a lot
more electricity out of this and we can
shave those margins down to a more
reasonable level rather than excessively
large margins so that's also part of the
so some states have had decent emissions
cuts just because of upgrades in
nuclear which is great and then you
mentioned before the high barrier to
entry sometimes with the cost of capital
needed to start a nuclear reactor and so
nuclear we have a question says nuclear
power is distinguished from most other
technologies in that its cost increases
with time and so do you do you agree
with that and if so why does that happen
I totally disagree with that it's
arbitrary the price of energy is
arbitrary if you think about energy what
is it all predicated on right it's all
predicated on this asset this commodity
fossil fuel commodity that started out
as coal and it was a small thing to do
you know whatever they did with steam
engines at first and then gradually you
got oil and then gasoline kerosene
gasoline and natural gas and became this
multi trillion dollar industry the
fossil industry so we predicate our
whole grid all of the energy that we get
is predicated upon feeding money to this
commodity industry it's not
infrastructure like you should be
infrastructure should be like building a
hospital building roads building you
know sewage for cities and stuff it
should be thought it was that nuclear
power just like renewables is power for
the people it's about ideas using
smarter not using resources to get
energy they're using some resources but
it's about using just really smart
science to be able to get a ton of
energy out of the tiniest little it's
mind-boggling and it's a huge threat to
the fossil industry but the fossil
industry side a good ride
I think they've it's time for them to
sort of pass on the torch and it's time
for the world to start thinking energy
more as a public good then as a business
commodity driven type of thing that's
all for the benefit of enriching a bunch
of folks that don't necessarily have the
best interests of the planet in life but
I think we can point to economic
statistics so the question referred to
that what we call a negative learning
curve in economics and there are
examples of positive learning curves and
in nuclear and I believe Korea is an
example of that right so maybe we could
just turn that question around to the
panelists and say what do you think
would have to change
for nuclear to go on a positive learning
curve again yeah so I mean I think one
of the things that's important to keep
in mind is that the cost escalation of a
lot of the plants in the United States is
not representative of the global
experience around the world you know in
a lot of the costs the united states
have gone up due to a lengthening of the
regulatory and permitting process and a
wide variety of other challenges is very
easy to challenge a lot of these
projects and then subsequently through
the court delays drive up the lion's
share of these costs also American labor
is a lot more expensive than labor in
other countries so if you compare the
plant construction costs in South Korea
which has some of the least expensive
power plants the other thing that
they've done is they've standardized
designs you know so in the United States
we have about roughly a hundred-ish types
of reactors they're all a little
bit different as opposed to you know
South Korea kind of made a choice if
we're gonna have one plant design we're
gonna standardize this and then we're
gonna come down that learning curve so
that's all coming down the learning
curve necessitates some sort of a
standardization so then you build it
over and over again and then those
people that were you know helping to
construct this reactor can apply those
learnings the subsequent reactor and so
on and so forth and and that's where
you're really getting a lot of the
savings so I think you know the cheapest
electricity reactor construction
projects in the world are gonna be
driven by the South Koreans driven by
the Chinese where they're really
standardizing a lot of these designs and
building a lot of the same types of
plants because that's really where
you're gonna get the savings so Tyler has
summarized a very elegantly although I
just wanted to add that if you're
interested about this topic I would
recommend reading Jessica Lovering's pieces
on this she also appeared in the
movie I believe so she has some excellent
work on
this topic okay well on that note we are
out of time and we greatly appreciate
appreciate each of you panelists taking
time out of your day to be here today
and sharing your knowledge with our
audience and also out in Internet-Land so
everybody please thank join me in
thanking the panelists
and also a big thank you Camila Montes de
Oca for making this panel
discussion happen thank you